I'm a huge fan of veep and I've told you
this but everyone in my family our
favorite character is your character
absolutely hilarious you're so funny on
that roll we have a clip here from veep
and I believe this is your character
started out in like an honorary role you
know as an honorary sort of an honorary
mayor is that right so this season
pretty early on to become become like a
honorary mayor of Lurleen yeah and then
pass slowly like he starts to like make
his way amazing things start happening
who's the nicest guy in the world
but now you're you're like an assistant
to the government yeah I'm a governor's
assistant yeah and and you're rising up
everyone else is trying to claw their
way up you're just a nice guy who's
rising up magically and everyone said
feels like I think this is a scene where
the governor is no fan of yours I
believe and want to stop you and you're
just a pleasant guy let's think about
this but from Vina welcome to your new
office lieutenant governor's split there
we go wait what No so were you sticking
on intern oh no no when I was a summer
intern for lieutenant governor plas go
back in the seventh grade having a much
bigger office we got to get the morbidly
obese out of Iowa I mean last night I
tried to find his 1-9 chain restaurant
to eat at and Yelp basically told me to
go foot rucker myself sounds like a
settings issue okay now listen we gotta
get you national Richard okay so that's
why I've already booked you on Mike Lynn
talk and I cancelled Oh governor
Ballentine you think you're hot [ __ ]
splay first human mayor of Lurleen
straight to lieutenant governor just a
few months thinking well now you're a
nice cold dog turd because you're not
getting my job governor we have the
utmost respect save it Manhattan date
rape mystery
water up and doctor bag